- When I first became
aware that Donald Trump
was actually running for president,
my thought was, this can't
possibly be happening.
- Basically for 25 years
Donald Trump had been flirting
with the idea of running for president.
It was basically a way for him
to get a bunch of attention.
- The combination of a clearly
undisciplined candidate
like Donald Trump and a
handful of incompetent,
republicans are seemingly
competent republicans,
suggested a repeat of
the cycle we saw on 2012.
- You know, a lot of news outlets
had already put their
best reports on Jeb Bush,
he was supposed to be the
front runner at the, sort of,
presumed Republican nominee
at, you know, a year out.
- I guess I really didn't
take it as seriously as
I could have or should have.
- It's hard to actually
think that this person,
who's a showman, is going to launch
this credible campaign for president.
- Yeah, so, early 2014 I arranged
to interview Donald Trump
on his plane, so I spent
two days with Trump
down at his kind of beach
side compound in Palm Beach,
interviewing him, getting to know him.
The piece that I wrote,
kind of, called him out
for 25 years of pretending
to run for president,
just to kind of get attention.
I predicted quite confidently
that he never would
actually run for president.
- Yeah, so when Trump announced
he was running for president
he came down with his wife on
this escalator in Trump Tower.
- Coming down the escalator,
I think that few of us
will forget that image.
- With the escalator, I think,
the mood was sort of, jolly about it.
I mean, I think that goes
for a lot of newsrooms.
- I was actually up in New Hampshire
covering a Jeb Bush campaign rally.
And I remember just sitting
in this like town hall
in New Hampshire like
watching the tweets come in
about Trump's announcement
and I remember, I think
I tweeted something like,
I feel like I'm being punk'd.
- When I first saw a
Trump event in person,
I think that's when it
all sort of came together.
It was just that kind of political event
I'd never seen before.
- When I was in a cab
ride back to my hotel
and I was on the phone with my editor,
kind of giving my read
out of what had happened
and kind of talking about
insider political analysis
and I remember all of
a sudden the cab driver
just like, was obviously
eavesdropping on me.
The cab driver barked something like,
"Trump is winning cause he
understands real Americans".
I remember just getting out of the cab
and being like, okay, this
is probably happening.
- When he went after John McCain
for having being captured
as a prisoner of war
and there was all this condemnation
that came from the Republican Party.
For him to be able to say what he said,
which was actually in many ways,
a criticism of all prisoners of war,
and to not have it affect
his support whatsoever,
that was that moment where I thought,
this isn't just your average Kennedy.
- I would say that my own
feeling about this really turned
around the time of the Paris attacks.
And Trump's ability to
capitalize from the Paris attacks
and kind of open up a new front,
policy front which is the ban on Muslims
into the United States, his
vote share like went up.
So I kinda had two conclusions.
First, the Republican
base is really eating
whatever Trump is cooking with regards to
bigotry and nativism.
And second, I don't think
the Republican Party
institutionally is
equipped to deal with it.
And if it's not equipped to deal with it,
then I'm not sure how
they're going to stop it.
- The thing that I realized is that
I underestimated Trump because I thought
that all he wanted was attention.
And what I think he
really wanted was respect.
And that's more deeply
rooted than I ever realized.
It goes all the way back
to when he was kind of
this outsider kid in Queens,
who wanted to live in Manhattan
and be accepted as a true Manhattan elite.
And he's kind of had this
outsider status anxiety
his entire life and I
think that I didn't realize
how deeply he felt that
and how that would fuel him
to do something so kind of outlandish
as actually run for president.